i'm gonna put on to finish my definition
i'm gonna put on
two more words that's it just two more
words okay
and i'm just gonna use as best as i can
the language we've already developed
right because we just established what
adding and subtracting is right
yep okay this is coming on to what
kavala was mentioning okay
multiplication multiplying i think the
simplest way to understand it
is it's repeated hey
that's all it is isn't it come on think
about it
right example okay uh three
times five what is three times five of
course you can start to talk about
factors
because that took like an area or
something but really what it means is
well
it's three and then you add three again
and then you do it again and you do it
five times
right so you are putting together
you're adding on five sets that are all
the same size
three namely yes
yeah that's right well if i'd written it
like this
then it would right i know we tend to
think of these as the same
but they represent different ideas right
like
you know the fact that multiplication is
commutative
is not immediately apparent because not
all operations
are right so anyway okay
so therefore you can probably see where
i'm going to go for division it's
it's repeated subtraction
but it's a little different it's a
little different
okay
oh sorry it's an atm machine okay
so it works a little bit different to
this
okay for instance if i said 15
divided by five what does that actually
mean why in what way is it repeated
subtraction
what it means is how many times can i
subtract five
before i have nothing left okay and the
answer is well
i shouldn't say equals i can do it three
times i can do once
twice three times right and that's when
i have nothing left in my set
okay so that's why three times
that's the answer okay now now you can
see
why i had to establish this because
that's going to be our gateway to think
about what this means right
division by zero okay
so example
okay let's consider what is one divided
by zero
all right so if i take this basic
basic basic definition right it's well
how many times can i take away zero
and you're like well well i can take
away one zero i can take nola
i still haven't i still haven't got to
my set which had nothing in it yet right
so you notice aha
there's three here how many here
answer answer infinite right
infinity okay so you might think okay
so does it seem fair to say
this okay now i'm gonna i'm gonna push
further on this a little bit right
because one of the ways that
mathematicians solve problems like this
is we say okay
you got a problem here's one way to
approach it
let's approach another way okay because
you know you guys actually know a lot
more about division
you know that it's more than just
repeated subtraction okay so for
instance let's consider
let's consider these let's get to these
numbers okay one over one
one over zero point one one over zero
point zero one
all right and i can i can keep going
okay so
there we go no prizes what's it equal to
one one divided by 0.1
it's 10. 1 divided by 0.01
okay all right so you can see where this
is going right
so now this is a different kind of
argument
but this if it kept going
it seems reasonable to say well
yeah now this is interesting i've
approached the same
problem from two completely different
angles
and i've got the same answer
okay so this seems promising seems
promising
but there's a problem it's a big problem
okay
and the problem is you know this game
right this game that i played here with
one divided by something and then
divided by other things and so on i can
play with other numbers too
can't i for instance i could do it with
two
right q over point one two over .01
and so on right now all of your numbers
right they're going to be twice the size
you're gonna get two
and then 20 and then 200 but they're
tending toward the same thing
right they're tending to infinity
so that means this is where this is
going is two over zero
right so apparently
1 over 0 is equal to infinity
and 2 over 0 is equal to infinity right
it's like well if you have if you have
these two things divided by the same
they should be they should be equal
right
now you see the reason why it was so
important to go establish this right
is that you can see this is not just
playing a game we've
broken not just rules we decided or
invented right but something which we
knew
to be fundamentally wrong here's one
i should put in this hand sorry here's
one and here's two
and they are not the same right they are
two sets and they are of different
sizes so this is this is wrong this is
wrong it can't be
okay which means that this can't be
which means that none of that
is true okay therefore it's undefined
now okay so then comes the question well
then
okay we call it we call it right
undefined but why do we call it that
is it just because it's like well i
don't know okay and i'll show you why
i'll show you why let's come back to
this okay let's come back to this
okay now i approached it from from this
angle and i was heading
from you know this bigger number one to
point one point one and i was getting
towards zero that's the way i did it
right
i approached it now there's other ways
to approach zero you know
you don't have to just come down from
one towards zero
you could go for instance from
minus one and go up towards zero i can
do that can't i one over
this i don't know about this i'm still
approaching zero
i know i'm still gonna get there minus
0.001 and so on i should still get to
one over zero
okay but what happens minus one
minus ten minus a hundred
minus a thousand where's this goal
this is not going to infinity
it's going to negative infinity okay now
this is where we get to the crux of the
issue okay
undefined why do we call undefined i
used to think you know
you get your calculator out and you
punch it in and it's like math error
because you know because it's undefined
you look it up on wikipedia
you're like a mathematician is just lazy
they're like ah i don't know what it is
we'll just not define it
no in fact
undefined it's undefined because
it's undefined a ball right
there is no number you can pick that
makes
sense right because you know you put
this and some other guy will say well
but i can make it equal this
in exactly the same way you do right so
there's equal sort of um
bitters for the crown of what one over
zero
is equal to yes
okay so so so this stuff here right
you can do it visually right you've got
this right this is what we started with
start at one over one which is like here
right
and then we decrease the value of the
denominator one over x right
so we were going this way and off we go
up to infinity but you guys know what
the other side of the graph looks like
right
that's the other side of one over x and
off it goes down to negative infinity
right so it's like where am i going well
the answer is
i can't be going anywhere right
that's right that's right the technical
way of saying this is the limit does not
exist okay so it's undefined because you
can't
define it it's not just because we
haven't worked out what it's equal to
yet
it's because we tried to work it out and
you just get completely
random things okay so that's why one
over zero
is undefined because it can't be defined